vladimir putin's move is a major
escalation in this crisis
first he staged a televised meeting of
russia's national security council where
he made a show of considering appeals
from his top aides on whether to
recognize that two russian-backed
breakaway states in ukraine as
independent
hours later he made a televised address
look at the weapons of nato it would be
possible for them to control russia's
airspace with medium and long-range
missiles and ballistic weapons they
could attack sites throughout russia in
less than 30 minutes i do not doubt they
plan to attack as they have in the past
[Music]
the self-declared republics of donetsk
and luhansk are in a state of high alert
after their leaders advised their people
to evacuate and told them ukraine is
mounting an offensive that's a claim
ukraine denies
but there's now a real risk that
russia's forces could roll into what
ukraine describes as temporarily
occupied territory that's because with
formal recognition of independence
russia could present itself as answering
a request for help
the united states of america and other
partners and of course ukraine where for
quite a long period of time were saying
that to provoke the conflict the false
lag operations will be will be organized
by russia federation and this case is
exactly the example of such a false flag
operation ukraine's foreign ministry
says it's dealing with dozens of fake
incidents and false flag operations it
says they're all intended to build up as
excuses for potential war
and one of the byproducts is fear
instilled into the lives of hundreds of
thousands of civilians living in the
breakaway republics
the suffering may become so much worse
for these people and millions of others
what was decided in the kremlin on
monday
could be one more step closer to war
andrew simmons al jazeera kiev